aquí hemos dividido a media luz
antes de la guerra con rusia saya dirige
a su propia agencia de eventos
ahora él y su hijo utilizan su furgoneta
para transportar agua a través de mi
cola y desde hace casi tres semanas la
mayoría de habitantes hacen cola en los
distintos puntos de distribución de la
ciudad para abastecerse de agua
los que no pueden arreglárselas solos
tienen que contar con la ayuda de
voluntarios como esas
esto es agua técnica use la sólo para
lavar y la otra es agua potable de la
tienda
para tatiana esta ayuda es una bendición
no está para el baño
tengo una enfermedad que afecta a mi
sistema nervioso y me impide moverme
puedo moverme un poco por el apartamento
pero salir es difícil
los vecinos de tatiana tras ver a saia
le piden el mismo favor
saya trabaja de la mano de una
asociación de voluntarios conocida como
df la asociación fue creada después de
que el gobierno ucraniano les pidiera a
los ciudadanos que ayudarán a construir
puestos de control ya fabricar cócteles
molotov al comienzo de la guerra desde
entonces 400 personas se han adherido a
la asociación que recibe donaciones de
ucrania y del extranjero
la de efe responde a todo tipo de
necesidades incluidas las de los
voluntarios de la defensa territorial es
el caso de este veterano que sirvió en
afganistán y que ahora pone su
experiencia militar a servicio de su
ciudad
el gobierno nos ayuda a lo mejor que
puede
pero hay interrupciones por lo que
necesitamos alimentos comida enlatada
ropa uniformes
para estos defensores de mi cola eve
este apoyo no puedes y no subirles la
moral
por supuesto que te hace feliz ver que
la generación joven es tan patriota
cuando dejan todo a un lado y vienen a
trabajar cuando cargan entregan hacen
cosas eso demuestra que ucrania
prosperará y que ganaremos
esta actividad continúa en el interior
del edificio donde se instalaron los
voluntarios por su proximidad a la línea
al frente mykolaiv recibe a muchos
desplazados que llegan con poco equipaje
buscamos y clasificamos por orden es
para una niña de siete años y un niño de
cuatro tenemos pedidos como éste que no
significa en la talla para los
refugiados para las personas necesitadas
efe
estas necesidades no se limitan a la
ropa otra parte del edificio alberga una
farmacia improvisada donde algunos
voluntarios con experiencia médica
intentan ayudar pero dado que los
combates no cesan no siempre es fácil
satisfacer todas las peticiones
realmente necesitamos botiquines
tácticos para nuestros chicos que están
luchando
necesitamos torniquetes necesitamos
anestésicos especialmente inyectables
necesitamos vendajes hemos trágicos de
emergencia y sustitutos sanguíneos
aunque este tipo de equipos técnicos son
difíciles de conseguir los voluntarios
pueden al menos ayudar a subirle la
moral de los que están en el frente
antigua fotógrafa irina prepara
calcomanías dibujadas a mano para
colocarlas en paquetes que se les
enviarán a las tropas ucranianas
la idea de las calcomanías no ayuda pero
esta es la mía es solo para hacer más
felices a los soldados
al menos recibirán calcomanías o una
postal
vladimir es el hombre detrás del ateo
efe un pianista de jazz que espera que
la asociación sobreviva al conflicto
actual
aunque ahora este lugar está medio
arruinado dentro de dos años cumplirá
200 años y esperamos tener la
oportunidad de restaurarlo esperamos que
la guerra termine y que podamos celebrar
nuestra victoria
y fue enviado hoy
la primera victoria de mico life está en
los esfuerzos que los voluntarios han
logrado poner en marcha a través de
estos proyectos pero con la ambición de
rusia de avanzar hacia el sur de ucrania
considerado un objetivo importante los
voluntarios también se preparan para
afrontar días más difíciles